and oh so I was at the Starbucks and the
guy the guys like what do you want and I
said oh I'll get an iced americano but
do me a favor can you put less water in
it and just more ice now for those of
you that don't know what a my iced
americano is here's what it is okay it's
literally shots of espresso with water
in it and that's it and then an ice and
that's it okay that's what I get that's
my thing iced americano with
iced americano I don't put in
it so whenever they say like do you want
room for now I by the way do you want
room for nah I don't want room for
I'll just pour some out if
I need it and I'm not gonna be the
that pours it out in the trash
can because that's pieces of
because then the trash cans leaking and
you're making everyone's job difficult
I'll go outside to do it I'll do it in
the sink that they always have or
whatever the or I'll pour it on my
opener if it's hot so I say to the guy
can you do me a favor and can you just
not put so much water in it and and and
put more ice in it now I've been getting
this drink for years and years and the
guy looks at me and says well I would
but that's literally impossible and I
said what and he says well an iced
americano is espresso with water in it I
said yeah I know and he said so I would
put less water in it but that's
literally impossible and I said and I
said oh whoa not it's not
okay I mean I didn't know how it is one
of those times were like when somebody
like tells you something that is just
not true and then you're like oh well
how do I say that the how do I say this
in response to how do I respond to this
guy without seeming like a
right because what he's
saying is wrong so I just said oh now
you could just put less water in it
right and he was like no and I said and
then I said well just put less water in
it and
said okay and then he put less water in
it so it's not literally impossible also
the fact that he said literally
impossible made me want to punch
up his face like a punching back
just say impossible okay